There's a lot that goes into movie-making,
especially huge productions like the Marvel
Studios mega-blockbuster Avengers: Infinity
War.
Between principal photography, adding CGI
effects, and reshoots, scheduling can become
a mind-bogglingly complex equation.
Often, studios like Marvel have to begin editing
before they've even finished filming the movie.
So it's no wonder that mistakes start to creep
in.
And despite how awesome Avengers: Infinity
War is, even the biggest blockbuster event
of the year isn't immune to editing mistakes
- as one eagle-eyed Marvel fan discovered
when he found a glaring continuity error that
somehow completely slipped past everyone at
Marvel Studios.
What is this huge mistake?
Well, during the climactic battle at the end
of the film, Thanos is shown grabbing Vision
by the throat on two separate occasions.
Everything you ever knew is a lie!
Okay, so maybe it's not that big a deal.
In fact, you probably didn't even notice it
when you were watching Avengers: Infinity
War in the theater.
But once the mistake was pointed out by Reddit
user FoorAJ in a handy graphic, it's pretty
hard to miss.
The scene in question takes place just after
Scarlet Witch uses her hex power to destroy
Vision's Mind Stone, preventing Thanos from
completing the Infinity Gauntlet and destroying
half the life in the universe.
Unfortunately, Thanos uses the Time Stone
to rewind history, and once Vision is alive
again, he grabs the synthezoid by the throat.
When Scarlet Witch tries to intervene, Thanos
clobbers her.
After she hits the ground, the camera pans
back over to Thanos and Vision and Thanos
is shown reaching for Vision's throat even
though he just had his big, meaty villain
hand around it a few seconds before.
Thanos then lifts Vision off the ground, holds
him in the air by his throat, and scoops out
the Mind Stone.
We know Thanos' whole "thing" is taking tyranny
to the extreme and being as over-the-top as
possible not quite as dramatic as the late
Loki but pretty close but a double chokehold
seems a bit excessive.
Though it's definitely detectible and certainly
won't go unnoticed now that it's made the
rounds on the internet, this mistake doesn't
really affect the overall quality of the movie
at all.
Even after learning Thanos grabs Vision by
the throat twice in the span of a few seconds,
every Marvel fan would likely say that Avengers:
Infinity War is still as action-packed, at
times hilarious, and ultimately heart-wrenching
as it was before anyone noticed that small
editing mistake.
And more than that, this certainly isn't the
first time a Marvel Cinematic Universe installment
has featured an error, or at least a perceived
error.
In Spider-Man: Homecoming, for instance, a
graphic stated that the film took place eight
years after the events of the first Avengers
movie, when it should have only been 5.
And remember the mysterious case of Bucky
Barnes' changing birthday?
His birth year has been variously listed as
1916, 1917, and 1922.
And there was the car dent that fixed itself
in The Avengers, the money that magically
flew out of a wallet in The Incredible Hulk,
and the disappearing headset in Iron Man.
And… well, we could go on and on, but why
nitpick some of our favorite films?
If anything, these little harmless goofups
are just reassuring proof that while the Avengers
may be superhuman, the folks at Marvel who
make these great films are just normal people
like the rest of us - people who sometimes
make mistakes, and sometimes make great movies.
It just makes us more excited than ever to
find out what happens in Avengers 4, which
is scheduled to arrive in theaters in May,
2019.
Will the dead return to life?
Will the Avengers prevail?
Will Thanos choke Vision a third time?!
Whatever happens, we can't wait to find out.